however believe my name is a nice view
super scientist at skies and
bioinformatics you are taking in Redwood
City and today I'm glad that I'm going
to put them to you and sample2 in
psychology called explosion as I say in
my sleep cycle and it's about the role
of my quad an email an interaction in a
specific tutoring caffeine a man called
on Demetria we'd undo me PL carcinoma
the story i'm going to present and came
from that PLO expectations by a chinese
group and they were looking at both my
cotton and marinate restriction to and
look at the potential role of these mac
when calling in stage 1 e HC i will use
that and cleaning and for the
convenience flood so first of all let me
tell you what we have concluded m using
that someplace inside approach and
looking at my clamonade and there's an A
and provide a component of that story we
have found that one strong transcription
factor called st des is an important
things likely an important player into
no portion in dec using the triton
balance formed exhibition we were able
to notified that SPD expert in the world
in cell migration and cell invasion it
acts as a tumor suppressor or whether we
detected that the transcriptional hold
on driven by that molecule seems to be
any duties there follow following the
selling version to polarize so gunpoint
we found that me up to 66 1266 five feet
was able to target with high level of
tradition spds for download aggression
and in need if you look at the prospect
on in garden inpatient 47 lat particular
module eight
we have found also that spds is one of
the downstream targets of a major
network driven by auto fill in one EG
and one which is an important player in
consolidation that network called causal
Network eating board in invasion of
personal our scalps and it will
demonstrate that later and finally we
have also discovered at to violence
emissions that replace a g2 is see where
fun in that pitiful are going to last
example of spds and that violent was
able to induce the likely lots of
functions so this is the outline of your
presentation I'm going to give you a
background on Dec and describe the study
i'm going to introduce to you to the
notion of the sunporch inside cajun
software tuna sandwiches and it's from
the powerful approach to understand
biology going to explore the data
analysis and the expression labels from
the NSA data and welcome to color value
and finally we are going to bring a
political interpretations highlighted
for this early stage of eec and atoms
for my patients we are going to look at
the transcriptome internal profile look
at the micro RNA profile welcoming to
identify microarray enter network of
importance in ready ISA collections we
are going to identify and sit down is he
causing volumes any well going finally
at the eec cuisine violence which key by
quality marina network and we're going
to cook it
so the other museum is the structure
which is affected by that calcium it's a
real you love if it is a layer consists
of three important layer so logical
layers the main inspected is under them
and compaction stratum functionaries
that's a tissue undergoes similar and
physiological change swapped cycle and
during them for you implantation it its
function as a tissue remodeling and like
structures 240gb years it's a process
which is regulated by Orion steroid in
many cytokines and growth factors eec
all on doma theatre cinema in general is
the most common and gynecology called
night engine see in Europe and North
America stretch so very important public
health issue the most common type is
called on the weight while you eat on
the nucleon adenocarcinoma easy it is
the point of that to decree many others
type of automatically ultra finem a path
name here specifically the eec is an
estrogen-dependent remo its engineer are
preceded by many biological processes
coming from in doing from Inca pages
where typically garages and so on a term
I know this seventy-five percent of the
women have that this is confined to the
uterus and it's called stage one in
stable phase the five-year survival for
stage 1 patients is very good news from
80 to 90 persons are Webber
unfortunately 10 to 20 we developmental
studies for their business most of these
eec Oscar low-grade tumors name g1 or g2
and it means that the cells of modena 30
well
differentiated cells to humble ourselves
and if you the early stage means that
the spread has not been beyond the
details the risk factors are limors the
main one and aluminum foolish but some
cases are criminal Kazan obesity is
starting to play a non-factor on that
and estimates that out fifty percent of
these other mythical come sail and us
are attributable to excess and ability
knowing that they eat this it is going
to increase its going to be a major
issue for that type of country nearly
parity debate and diabetes mellitus as
well as a user contraceptive pills are
among the others which factors the
patient are generally treated with
surgery radiation chemotherapy hormone
therapy so specifically that study first
of all the dollars in deposited in the
NRH shops with archive database under
all that and a softy number free though
women have been diagnosed with stage one
to web stage 1a and one was stage 1 d
all we're great one we are going to find
a school heart because of that webinar
that who are the two stage 1a and here's
the stage 1 D in the paper nothing has
been described to indicate that the
signal thing has been added an na na as
well as a smaller than a level using it
in a high-tech sequencing of the 20 and
I just something on tumor tissue to
which processing and look for the mlx
high-quality man a sequencing with an
app to the genome Eddie 19 years in
Tibet and match a rid of a line to the
transcriptome and some ball the obvious
seven cufflinks have been used to get
create an expression level for the
smaller than a sequencing wings and they
have been mapped to the genome using the
booty software smaller than a type the
line to the micro and a precursor make
you Michael Anna in mid layers using the
voice 21 visions statistical tests have
been used for they have my botany target
prediction they use targets can pretend
we're on them and finally for working an
ex MV and in del detection big elusive
askin as well as a nabob falter and
making them a noble is a one of the
product of the Cajun by an automatic
street right now we are going to see
that we are going to use measurement
strategy to explore the biological that
come share in this free woman so what do
we mean by the control and guidance on
part two inside first of all this is
really the first time for biologists and
I'm a biologist and let bagon politician
that we can from the sample iteration
extract in the oily or the DNA target
engagement library construction
sequencing we can analyze the data for
looking at the variance and mapping and
looking at the differential expression
but finally we can interpret that
biology you great-looking focus on bond
as well has affected password and many
other things and the good news is flood
the euros guys in a ziploc meaning you
should keep them Halloween it has to go
through this picture one in particular
could have been used here the gene with
proven an egg for having am small mmm
mmm mmm mmm expressions to be using
angiosperms then use I seek sequencing
here and welding to talk for the data
analyzed
and about that biomedical equipment
products as well as for the
interpretation and you keep an eye on as
Reese energy transfer analysis here this
is a couple of icons to demonstrate
guadalupe products on the keys to the
software and to the political
interpretation here so again that some
part 2 inside can be adapted to any type
of explanation here we are going to look
for these fit issues we and the tissue
have been obtained after surgical
resection we exploit and the total RNA
we could have used tige niquette hell we
are going to send that to sequencing
isaac in you Nina I've been used and
women to process the data for that
analyzes reading that I you with each
engine McGowan's could be accessed we're
going to get expression profile for the
energy level and we are going to call
from the energy project on the vial and
finally we are going to set up by the
biology using engine EG pathway analysis
as well as in chi by another is in and
just connected the way so let me
introduce to the biomedical genetic work
bench it's for the data analysis
processing during that webinar i'm not
going to go in depth of a despotic boot
because we have a wonderful and webinar
and both your flyers application on
paper that described in depth all of
these different solutions that we have
informative session with but biomechanic
workbench and can deal with whole genome
sequencing as well as a whole exome
sequencing targeting over transcriptome
sequencing
this is what we have do today as well as
cheap seek that and structure I've been
the software has been created and our
has created and workflow that are ready
to use four fingers from polar curve
study there is a simple and one-click
analysis of genomics DNA sequence icon
click on panels but today we are going
to you that streamlining integration
with engine keep askin LEDs coli DNA and
jimmy key valiant analyzes and we can
also create our own workflow which is a
very nice way and to be to explore by
loading inverter which is what I've done
today so if you use it a biomechanical
Jamie wall bench to IPA and you look at
expression profile you're going to go
from the sequencing the alignment the
quantitation as well as the differential
expressions if you select the data so I
selected that Chinese that I've external
data I have dominated the fescue five
from the SF file I haven't posted at
first to file to DX then I have set up
the elastic analyzes available by
selecting a reference genome mapping
options and expression their goal see
the results here I have looked at the
micro llanelli world using the village
for each 21 and doing the same then
finally I have set up an experiment and
it's constructive all that could have
done that at the genial and they
explained was to move s usages of not to
the night feat on significant transcript
and put the data to all the idea for
analysis then we can call volume from
and that elastic sign in here in a
cooking 14 so the first step of
hierarchical as producing
we are going to select a workflow our
custom workflow and for coining the
variance and expression profile from the
fashion week we have done that here
using the energy vibrant and a sad
expression value but I've selected to do
a custom workflows on the weed directly
obtained from seriously expressions or
file analysis and this is the workflow
that consists to look at snv in the L in
Asian for study team for negative and
mapping that to the corresponding
sequent leaving an indelible and finally
world into sent that to engineer valiant
analogies for anomalies techny
introduced to you also to ingenuity
pathway analysis which is the most
powerful tool to gay for Biological
interpretations that or structure of
interpretation is based on a very
powerful knowledge base columns in the
key knowledge base which is very clear
database which PhD student appears the
scientist and curated thousands of
trouble of finding the reading Madonna
people view literature's and have
impulsively in the very structure of the
coal ontology way and of the night lay
in order for engine give away by of
analysis as well IPA to be able to dig
in database page the corresponding
signing of a jealous that you can
display to be right over the back road
it's a very powerful scripture from
which we can explore by Reggie from that
we can find some soup Jing you can view
disease from show you which is budgeting
we never think about single gene over by
the disease here this is the case of
caspases we can know what are the
passwords that caspase-8 vino to one of
the micro neta target essentially that
molecule what regulates how did you
speculate by what it binds what is the
role in cells and solve them finding
literally you kind of saw
fighting for one particular genus we are
very powerful now because we can look at
you man I performed at the mouth nun
level which is an example just decades
which is on the chromosome 2 locusts
have actually 6 / environment and you
look at the red signal in we can look at
canonical pathways and using what it
will activity critter so what is the
canonical pathway is relative signaling
cascade or metabolic cascade which had
confronted throughout the scientific
community and they are the one by this
PhD scientist that with people of Duty
conscious and ever going to draw here
that example of the BNP of tgf-beta
seeing any the more it will actually be
predictor is another way to simulate the
activity optional but removal tool based
on expression pattern or mimicking some
effects of a drug all unblock here we
have their blog also and feature
collapse from enemies which is a feature
that answer fundamental questions in
biology and looking for potential driver
photon construction on wire Abu
particular program and that and I will
show that to you later during the
webinar is explicitly you will right now
because we can determine if one
particular missile can be a national
surveys on the pattern of expression of
your gene in your data set and we can
educate which direction that regulators
is activated already BTW and we have
many other things that we can roll and
connect these regular stuff together and
have a mechanistic where whole quadrant
way could explain that later we can also
look at a design function and we can
determine based on what we call dancing
effect energies based on the pattern of
extraction of your genes we can
determine the quantity through your
biological processes of a set of
processes can be increased or decreased
cell movement seems to be in phase
infectious disease seems
to be liquid we're using the color code
to simplify with you finally we can look
at the regulatory ethics which mean tiny
that transcription and programmer was
talking about four layer or intervene on
to your data set with their productive
expression here they were all on a
privilege in and you tie that to
significant political processes function
of the odds of contract in each of the
column loss of so it's basically the
grout of any religious trying value
called for valuable processes and a set
of transcription factors that line
expression pattern we can look also the
micro minute I this winter which is a
feature that allows us to associate my
coordinate to na na target and using if
you're on set of algorithm we can also
explore all the molecules including
drugs and chemicals that have been
associated to particular this is of
interest and looking at all the findings
and they will active activity of that
nature and the impact of that molecule
on the disease but now we can also look
at what we call either profiler another
one's looking at splicing by on two
isoforms that other function event is in
a particular disease or processes and
looking at the relative expression when
you use for instance having a thick as
we do in that webinar we are going to
find out which other forms of key him as
one of two nations finally we can greet
network collateral networks we can use a
set of features called Villanova way
where you can cost work everything you
can imagine or one set of socialized
data and here this is the expression
pattern you can look at reagent you can
look at biomass codification and many
many other goodies
finally even if the five min of final
that we are constantly and update QC for
the 15 last years of ingenuity
knowledgebase creations you can import
your own findings in all knowledge base
only you will be able to see any
signings services exclusively useful for
people who do not want to share but of
specific property data they would like
to insect in a database so the three
patient of early stage 2 1 a 1 1 day as
I said red one we are going to
understand the transcriptome and we are
going to answer couple of specific
questions we are going to pull out the
signaling log metabolic pathway leading
ball and welding to find out if they are
activated or inhibited welcome to use a
canonical password feature for welding
to look for the underlying prescription
column using the epsilon i minus well in
to understand what biological processes
are involved in it work back using the
disease informations finally we are
going to look at an splicing violent
event arrest and find out how they are
regulated using either profile and this
is also a very important tool for
biologists is to highlight hypothesis
and we can do that choosing the coder
network in Nicaragua readiness we're
also going to understand America my
colony profile looking at them and it's
all get that that could be notified and
this target of the target to finish on
to express my colony in the concert
context and we are going to roll micro
nmn a network so important that we think
are important in that egcg more polish
so
step slide represents the different
chemical pathways be simian in cascade
and here I'm showing one of the
patient's collocation 332 i'm going to
call them 332 346 p-47d see their age
some clean them by their age and if you
look at that slide you are looking at
multiple things first of all we are
looking at the presence of your gene and
in your letter sets that overlap with no
chemical pathways constants there is a
lot of leaned in your data set that
overlap with the e I f2 signaling
pathways it is the presence of the minus
log P values so first of all you look at
the overlap so what are in your data set
what ginger of pleasanton which can
impact a little garlic and you can tell
right away that a lot of singing
metabolic pathways known are involved in
that team affiliation for extractions I
occasionally ng and taken turning and
many others but you'll notice also that
we have a set of color orange shadow
blue and sometimes great and it's a way
to determine what we call a pathway
activity analyzes that I mentioned here
in a bottle by doing that we are able to
determine and using calculation unit for
the zip code if one particular pathway
is activity all if one particular
pathway is maybe and it's very
interesting to look that 4,000 pathways
such as he is to signaling is actually a
curated according to a status to our
statistical algorithm but if you look at
our educational in a second timing which
hosted on the same movement and motility
they are blue indicating that according
to our prediction the sims 2 BBC
so here looking at that canonical
pathways feature of you right away and
go into the subject and understand that
for patient leave the key to their is
polish collection yet these canonical
password data associated by the way to
the DMV which is a bit alien to me some
kind of transition which is the starting
point of attachment of cells that are
going to start to migrate are inhibiting
so I wasn't a thing of combining these
three patients what I call to 32 3 46
and p-47 so see initiative a
presentation all what we call heat pad
all these three patients and a book does
not achieve canonical pathways a lot of
this pathway are very well known il-6 I
ok and take in people when you do that
you realize that two of the patients 332
p46 look alike they're fat them look
very much alike and he taking already
put on show and fact that p32 and 346
maybe the two-stage money and p-47 is
essentially i was watching pathways full
acceleration is ongoing in all of these
patients and movement is ongoing at its
current way it doubly passwords are also
not she should order to pass that's
where gamma is involved too so that
compile educate us what are the pathways
involved what are the direction and
hard-edged escape to each other's
between patients let's focus on what we
call a metabolic pathways and very
interesting equals 4 metabolic pathways
in that particular case we do not
calculate the disco so it's not a magic
reactions so it's an equilibrium between
two components but we can definitely
look at the overlap of the genes indeed
that with all of these known pathways
and at the top you realize of selective
force collection is fun throughout this
patient and black colleges system and he
and the legs I specifically look at the
patient p32 project right there we
indicate to me the importance of what we
call it what will affect so because i do
not know the direction of these pathways
are the activities or aggregate we can
nevertheless imagine that because we are
under two Malaysian second in the black
colleges is a really involved and in
fact the Wagyu effect two more cells use
I o'buck like old ladies pathways and a
lot kotori of normal cells and oxidative
phosphorylation even though we have a
strong google app that canonical pathway
is and a disadvantage of relax you is in
her tomb of relations so that's just a
way of getting a lot of body cannot
option just looking a little item
specific metabolic we're here for the
free patients time interesting to look
at another patients for the psyche of
the example and looking at a typical
transcription program in the early stage
member risk-free pension run for stage 2
a1 a1 z1 be that slide would present the
potential app store data with their
level of activity ready to be activated
when you look at the target don't swing
and the relative expression pattern we
know that all these target down stand
here in put in that first line are known
to be downstream of me one based on that
where I go to you find some that meet
sat seven page PDF that we are going to
talk about and fast are predicted to the
activity this is a reasonable prediction
based on what we know which team
operation needs and transcriptional
regulator are always set to the activity
to stop
and similarly two more minutes process
let's look at two other two fictional
regrets off called plz c18 as well as
peoples as you see one be these are
people who ask about the one I wanted
and if you use at that Display Network
button here you are going to end up to
that very nice figures in the software
we have call to I added another one
called x a.d.f too because it's
important in what I mean to say right
now these a 3some friction factor are
predicted to be activating and we know
that because we know the pattern of
expression of the gene that are here
English out of Stockholm and negative
expression based on their personal
expression were able to determine these
guys obsolete get to this activity in
other words they are being turned on and
it's really important in that case in
the patient 46 because these guys Dwight
and the fatty acid and a ser olmy w
pathways which is a key and which are
the key role in the true proportion of
any type of concepts if you look at the
statistical decision function you can
add them we have the capability
capabilities to have them using row
features that we have in our George if
you do that and you use the activity
predictions we're able to notice that
polish collection of cells as well as
information about cam is set in no ones
which means of
and predicted to be increased and here
we look at this fan pages of steroid as
well as liabilities of as well or what
it means activity so the conversion of
that slide is only taking that based on
the set of genes that are known to be
dancing of these three transcription
factor we think that this punctuation
photo has been turn on and they're able
to divide the inflammation about them up
and the Polish version of ourselves up
so it's very good information I don't
know we like to add also that each of
these arrows are clickable and
underlining there is finding the in
documentation throughout and all
knowledge base and we can even give you
a new permit ID and get the papers for
reading if for the photo full extent of
information now same has a pinnacle but
way we like to compare these optional
aziz in other words i would like to
compare with some scripts all program
that off section 332 346 mp4s Keller and
I specifically asked the feature to look
at growth factor and transcriptional
regulators and you can tell India that
right away the 23rd program seems to
define and distinguish the patient from
each other p 32 and 346 look alike again
and p-47 in default and i would like to
consult right on that only two days PDF
and the same i'm going to the roller
network in the sun terrace PDF which is
predicted to be activity based on the
pattern of expression of the genes that
you see in and that's very interesting
because that will include it involved in
the cell migration and invasion in p 32
MP 46 we think that SPD a strategy to be
activated so when that molecule is
activity it indicates the same migration
and invasion actually inhibited in peace
32 MP four five six
if you look at station 47 that movie
queen is inhibited or addicted to be
invited back and wraps or the cell
migration and invasion is actually
inducing 347 slide at the slide it
seemed that pizza e 2 & 3 47 and are in
the stage 18 MP 4017 stage Wendy so the
stage one end said one we are different
in the level of invasion of the
myometrium in other words the cells that
have been too morose in geography on our
stuff to move and start to migrate and
the first layer of our internal control
is the museum's stage 1 B is invasions
of the mayor mixing time interesting at
one of the duties and functions using
that dance from the technologies to see
what is important and what DFS between
expectations this is the heat map of
these and this isn't function based on
their activation risk or drawing EDT
Google's our activity and I will
specifically look at one function of
interest obviously which is the invasion
of chemo if you look at the illusion of
two more impatient 47 here we believe
that in vision to mobility to be
activated again this is based on the
expression pattern of the gym that I
learned to the Association injunction of
that particular functions so there's an
interesting to see that in 347 inversion
of Jamal is up let's look at couple of
molecule here I know if you can notice
that on the slide but molecule are
surrounded by the yellow hollow that any
case that you have a specific either
forms that are eventually express let's
look at them taking beta 1 we know that
antigen beta 1 is a very important
really
two invasions of any title and several
concepts and we knew that we believe in
working my Russian invasion to other
tissues so if you look at the gym heat
map in other words we looking at the
gene and the relative personal
expression that are known to be
associated to invasion of customer cells
throughout these vacations now we are
looking at their lead expression
profiles win done with energy vortexes
consumer read article H&M similar system
tomorrow if you look at on deck in beta
one that molecule here or the military
we have selected is operating in patient
47 so let's look at a dizer force
realize here that that particular phone
call itg be 10 10 these are creating
patient 57 some orders after they have
not been selected by the skies if you
look at the patient 4232 and 46 to
realize that many of their splicing
miles are actually download rigid so
what does it tell us it tell us that one
particular either form has an important
role in the region of justin amount
cells we probably need to explore that
this is why i send a promise we are not
sure we are going to have an ipod is to
test you and again later one either 40
10 may be involved in that inversion
processes it's a key function now I'm
interesting and looking at what it will
call the networks so what is the color
network briefly it's a network based on
the master regulator and a set of
regular cells that all together in a
very cool way because they are
associated to each other only by
activation and inhibition angie's viable
in the responsible
to explain plausibly the expression
vaginal here 352 target downstream none
of the $52 regular self second font what
we call a code a network hello us too
sometimes financial aid yet between that
mr. later and the target dance from here
in other world etn one may not have been
known to be connecting with as PDF but
with me out or whatever later when they
find a connection so that's a very
interesting and novelty that you can
explore and serve important point is we
can tie that close our network to
biological processes of the disease of
interest throughout the beginning since
the beginning of that maybe now I'm very
interesting in invasion rational self
because this will process that we shall
share the patient 47 from the patient
3246 that's the question what are the
intermediate that you can insert between
ed and one that master regulator and
original carcinoma and the software is
able to find for a gigantic sauce vinyl
chick database that answered in and say
even better one as well as alpha to
Tierra you off and Ed ends with all the
intermediate photos on intermarriage
between ed and one an aversion for CML
cells Warren important it big hose now
we have the network of regular dose that
also said to dump some some guitar
fluidly and allow us to explain when
invasion of customer is increased this
is the case here it's or watch auto
telling one response jalapeño into my
operations and here this is for mobile
you publish in surviving 2011 and that
money to leave involved in many tissues
and it certainly has
meantime you can conserve for the
production cell survival meta studies
and unique so that network was extremely
important to be highlighted here this is
a network that need to be tested need to
be validated in the lab for conservation
is certainly a very strong hypothesis to
understand why we have an increase of
stereo in vegetation 47 if you look in
the network freedom feel I have
surrounded by that shackle another
molecule as well as PDF that I talk
sensibly that Molly please weekend and
she had the yellow hollow and now using
the eyes of Buffalo which is the latest
feature we have relief that will help me
to discover one other area formal that
made drive with two more positions
because we are finding that associated
to the particular i just want and need
if you look at the comparison between
p32 346 and 347 p32 being here 446 being
in that colony in 347 lat colon we're
able to look at which either form long
weekend seems to be differentially
expressed and as an important political
woven 347 and the chase is there I hope
you can see that in p3 to let me tie the
phone is down leg reaching we don't know
what the expression is for p46 but I
check in the water lines little
significance but it's up regular
cleaning a p-47 so using that Idol
profiler I was able to dig through all
the different isoforms that are present
in my data set with developing station
and find out the goal of that particular
molecule I pointed on that weekend
because acne can has been involved
in National City to Morgan describing
fresh compare so it's certainly again an
exploration of the water that we can all
one that could be done under that
because it differentiates station 47
from the two other patients let's go
back to that cause our network driven by
on total in one we know that molecules
will na are on the regulation my
coronary relations in that other set the
team and Toledo my client profile and we
have done the same and here i am as the
questions show me from the scene if you
can't with a fortune to 1.5 see very
well I what are the micro Vanessa target
model in one and its focus on scene with
the ability the expressions for instance
near 31 31 is up regretting and Simone
let 7 a-5 p SW didn't you know and we
overlay the color code here we really
believe that on the prediction of hotel
in one being in field that and let 7a is
done regulating in the data set and
therefore we have a strong and tie here
well except and the 31 31 is able to
done with a cheap because if it were the
case that micronase should be done with
this is not the case so the summary of
that slide is yes we have my colony that
targets mini molecule i selected EG and
one and now we are able to understand
the role of this my client in organic
processes at the beginning i told you
about the tool co molecule activity
predictors and it's a very clear
simulator like a fight similar to
analyze the question here if i was
adding led 7 a-5 p as well as near 150
what would be
II the activity on the ceiling 110v in
78 as well um the inversion of Casanova
if you add that which is represented by
that red paint you are going to solve
that ed and one from orange to blue
which indicate that Indian one will be
created to the annuity and you can see
the major impact of these my colony on
the invasion of calcium ourselves it
turn blue if I may say which indicate an
individual of customers al windy
decrease so the addition of East
achieving my koala may help in relieving
that invasion of custom and reducing it
it's very testing equals the delivery of
my coordinate as telepathic against
concern is now in development so it's
certainly another idea to test in the
lab but we had something like 106 my
colony that were significant in your
letter fit if you do that and you use
the microphone a target feature that
allows to associate is my calling with
Amanda target based on the sequence we
Elijah over 15,000 email and are
potentially saga level which is not
actionable in the lab so we are doing
not to use this film cottagey to filter
in a selective way the internet targets
of interest cost point is you associate
the Michael Annett to specific that
effect of you see I was in Jersey
testing integration 47 which is to my
guess the only one deviations the one in
which each sales are starting to migrate
earth cells starting to migrate to the
myometrium so let's understand what is
the Civil inversion is is affecting by
doing that you realize that you would
use the number of and then it'll get
from 15,000 to 18 / it's a little bit
more and testing a weber of stick not
number so let's now use a set of filter
here we can figure by the confidence
level between the micron MLA I said
activity I direction and even want to
look at the exponent of server I wanted
to look at what I'll be high potential
using targets can as an algorithm to
define a particular my quality that you
see here and the pinnacle eliminate can
inject i selected also in the context of
two more muscular morphologies very
interesting to understand that email my
client and context in a specific
valuable processes and i have selected
only as target transcriptional regulator
here by doing that you obtain Lily the
minimal set of 12 my colony that are
differentially expressed at target only
16 mm this is much more actionable and
adjusting for validation in the lab here
this is a profession of nine of these 12
8 10 and 12 oldies 16 internet that are
involved in the station 47 so I just put
that networking you organized as PDF
which is done with related in the
patient 47 chemo and you look at this
specific Michael and another are
calculating I and focus only on
frustration regret all that are
negatively regulated fault and the
purpose of that top if you ask fer sher
to particular disease that are
significant such a significant realize
that the Polish version of console seems
to the increases orange seems to be
increased so that little Network helium
is able to bribe the poly fashion of
conserved apps so many of these micro
name net and MJ be very important player
so so far what did we actually using
that some point to inside up for cooking
on my corner and an attorney only we
know that if s PDF is equal in
segmentations and invasions
consumption program driven by that Louie
limiting therefore allowing the same
invention to provide the glow in the 347
patient's we know what type of my colony
is acrylic into target SPF the program
regulations and we have found out that
that's m'little involved in a network
extremely important for innovation of
questioning ourselves but I'm
interesting also in looking at
prudential ec coding volume and we have
down the processing of calling the biome
content that Evanescence and profile and
followed we are using the tool the
software solution kalenjin deviant
analogies it's in fact software that use
and to achieve filters to vivoli
non-causal bio and again to show that to
you that software helps you also to tie
particular violence to a particular
phenotype GI work does not obviously
that s PDF i was talking about either
blue color I'm going to expand later and
that's molecule that violent is
associated to other with the outcome
chef who is set all if you want an
immediate so it's very variable so high
did i do here I said incubation 47 for
that patient fit 47 between the two
mortgages on dunsmore well over five
hundred thousand volumes and we are
going to reduce using genetic and switch
off retail value key to a set of two
thousand comes out our driver by own gun
i'm going to use to connect to I p.m.
first of all I remove the prop 10 ounce
and usual suspect and we do that using
the confidence interval cheese and reach
age here again I'm not going to go in
detail because we have powerful with you
know that educate and train us all of us
about the function the features of all
these powerful and solutions that we
have size from we all come on we go the
chitin by informativa calm and you can
look at all these
flyers and many other goodies even I
also remove the buyouts phone in healthy
population we see interesting only in
the and patient populations and I use
for that become envious in particularly
i was able to remove a volume that are
present in what we call the elements
becomes community it's a very strong and
other basis of compiler one of these
twenty thousand genomes and you can
imagine using the filter to that
database you are going to exclude a lot
of false positive it's very powerful and
growing database yet but we are fine i
also and look for the pathogenicity or
the gain or loss of function of the
particular violent ir filter and I do
that using what we call it productivity
turbine out we can look at pathog need
to equip a progeny you can look at it
was April right under the bin associated
with the gamma function or loss of
function using these different purgatory
finally I could compare the volume phone
in my cage this is my controlling my two
mortgages mine address from consumer and
I use what we call a genetic analysis
feature and I have used a preset looking
for two more specific by another
presence in my team of tissues and
exclude them in the non and two most
issues using that filter here in finally
I try to have that idea of the class to
phenotype to identify biologically
relevant violence in my patient 47s can
be tied to undo material cough cinema so
I use the concept oil or by Anthony this
is not just a logical feature that this
is a preset system that allowed to look
at from Kershaw city most noted
phenotype as well as socially similar
processes and many other things
including TGA and database for that
pitch we are proposed today I didn't use
biological pharmacogenomics and other
studies or filter here but doing that I
was able to have over two thousand
volumes and I'm going to use these reefs
up to
thousand comes a drivable to interact
now with IPA so I was adjusting in SBS
and i was wondering if st gave a type of
violence and the answer is oh sorry i
was interesting in looking and that stf
complaining violent and i have connected
that by internal I this filtering system
to IPA to pay on the balance information
with the hospital in fact I have been
posted in cell activity the by on
getting a lot subscription as well as
there and I can collect medical genetics
and genomics rectifications thrown in
court and I have rerun the analysis and
look at this same yourself in regret so
we add in something now a new column
called volume again no solution I've
selective do that loss do that other
loss or likely loss of function I could
have selected the volume based on the
ACMG certificate I didn't hear and very
interesting enough I found that my body
to demented i SAT a BF x quality
non-regulation here in the two more
assistance from orientation 47 and i
noticed also that s PDF seems to add
likely loss of function its annotated by
2 minus 1 and doesn't matter number we
know we have a loss of function of
interest here it's a transcription or
lateral the disco which predict the type
of activity is low here but knowing all
paths and all elements of the goddess
since the beginning of that webinar
politic to that particular molecule in
its function its role we are able to
find out that s PDF family important now
for the patient 47 and we know that we
are from violence that affects these
functions let's go back to violent
energies to describe these violent here
we have a table we know the type of from
cibrian type of proteins i am the type
of translation impact
the region in which that variant is an
affecting and based on the sift and
polyphen which are going to predict the
damaging effect on the function of that
fraction is a leakage we have couple of
others identity of the genotype and the
type of component level sivaji number of
copy and so on but to visualize this is
the volume this is very own um samba
nothing that will it truly is on the
chromosome 6 and you realize that the
Alliance is in the last text on here
affecting the EPS binding site for me
papa and here we have a display also the
type of expression profile that Molly
tooney inpatient 47 he's done with Lady
visits people so it's done with it and
add violence that induces likely loss of
function of that particular and gene so
now if you go back to the y coordinate
na a network that I at all a couple of
slides earlier you can i light which of
these molecules I will likely loss and i
saw on leading wind sts so now what are
the conclusion we can get if you look at
that simple to inside a porch looking
now the three components I've used my
Colin a premier LA and the science we
know that molecule is done recruiting
347 and we have used and biomedical
mcwatt bench looking at the cultural
expression of the genes to finance we
have looked at the transcript file
Oakland ribbon bias PDF and we need
sanity to be in getting guys on
expression pattern of it and then a
target and we have used the upstream
analyzes in ith we could do that using
negative an education of the negative
fiscal we know that is PDF if you blog
inside my deductions inversion and
politically needed inpatient 47 and we
as you use the feature downstream effect
on is an idea we have also find out that
SPF is downstream targets or the network
women by hopefully one that into oxygen
volume
custom ourselves we could find that
using closer network and Elias the
cosine is working on it was and having
to put the disco and good ass and you
can ask me the activity of that big long
as well we also find out which my corner
can target as PDF foreign editions and
we have using that micron a target
filter feature of the critically
important to involve an idea of the IMF
michael and emmalin interactions we have
learned that microphone a man a network
and we know it's involved in cell
invasion in professional sales and
finally we are fine too violent mixed
sense with lesser g2c spawning that the
last legs on that affect the etf domain
yes PDF and levi and then do so lightly
loss of function and we have found that
using the engine chegar utilizing
software so i'm very pleased because as
the biology using biologic approach and
I'm load bioinformaticians using the
biomedical gym equipment I could do by
my own he applauded of the arena sagara
align to the general moment arrives i
use ensemble that could have used web
seek I could quantitate obtained
differential expression between the
sample I could call the right and could
send a data directly to IPA as well as
two ngt biotin is for violent in
notification prior authorizations and
biological interpretations using IPA I
was able to visualize differentially
type seen in the two mortgages
adjustable in these locations I could
understand with signaling pathways on
the wall in the two more possessions I
could discover the proton shouts from
scores of another induce our quest that
may drive that two more possessions i
was able to differentially and to
visualize the differentially expressed
lashing dial and their role i could
discover political process that
participate in the two most collections
and very importantly i was able to i
like new hypothesis that of
he needs to be testing and validating
and this I thought he could explain and
does it match in particular and using an
engine to dine at analogies I was able
to filter and identify easy cuisine vamp
I was able to tie these violence to the
micron in a network of important tonight
or earlier and finally I could obtain
data on their inside to begin their foot
off shore pathogenicity using sem so
it's a very powerful by automatic
approach that is an important as
solution for biology and biologists like
me and was very glad to present that
will be now and now i'm open to question
thank you